what's up get your crew welcome to the
weekly ketchup on YouTube where we bring
you the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and this week we're
talking about early reactions to
birds-of-prey season two of the
mandalorian Plus Oscar predictions so
let's do this
I wasn't the only damon got them looking
for emancipation birds of prey has
officially premiered and the social
reactions that are coming in had been
comparing the action to John wick and
the comedy to Deadpool but based on what
we know so far will this film be better
than its predecessor Suicide Squad let's
talk about it right now on the ketchup
hey there I'm Mark Ellis stepping in for
Nass Perez who actually has a great
reason for not being here but I'll let
her tell you about it hey guys sorry I
couldn't be there today I'm actually in
London interviewing the cast of birds of
prey I can't wait to see you next week
and hear what you have to say about the
reactions this film I'll see you next
week and I'm gonna kick it back to mark
now thanks
say hi to Abbey Road for meanness and
now that people have seen birds of prey
which opens wide on February 7th the
overall consensus on social media is
that it's flat-out a lot of fun and that
starts with Margot Robbie as Harley
Quinn Meg Downey on Twitter said that
the movie was an absolute blast
Harley feels exactly like the human
Looney tune she ought to be with Brandon
Rowe adding Margot Robbie is finally
given the spotlight in a film chock full
of chemistry and that chemistry is of
course referring to Robbie and the very
stacked cast like jurnee smollett belle
and mary elizabeth winstead who got a
lot of love as well like from BD who
tweeted it birds of prey told me
anything is that we need a whole lot
more canary and Huntress they are great
but there's a lot left on the boat so
yeah expect spin-offs but they aren't
the only members of this ensemble cast
that are turning heads our friend Eric
Davis tweeted that Ewan McGregor as
black mask and Chris Messina as Victor
Zsasz are so out of their minds in this
film probably my favorite villains in
this new era of DC movie plus a
shout-out to Rosie Perez this deals a
lot of scenes to other aspects of the
film that seem to add to the fun factor
are the soundtrack and the action
sequences which many have compared to
the John Blake franchise so
in other words lots of guns and
deservedly getting a lot of the credit
is birds of prey director Kathy Yan who
according to Scott Menzel on Twitter has
created a music infused celebration of
female badassery DC continues to take
big risks and push boundaries and
Millicent Thomas added to Kathy's film
is a criminally fun celebration of
sisterhood with some of my favorite
fight scenes in recent memory
early reactions are also saying that the
film nicely blends the impressive action
with just the right amount of drama and
of course comedy gig vibes nation
tweeted that there's a lot of fourth
wall breaking with many comparing it to
Deadpool and that comparison a common
one also stems from birds appraised
r-rated we are beyond birds of prey
picks up four years after the events of
2016 oscar-winning Suicide Squad
which is a rotten 27% on the tomato
meter but one of the few bright spots is
that film according to critics and fans
was Harley Quinn and birds of prey seems
to be starting off on a better
trajectory than suicides but giving
people what they wanted for the most
part Allyson Foreman called it a solid
breakup movie that is leagues better
than Suicide Squad in large part because
we got a rare glimpse into the rich
inner life of a female super villain but
Simon Thompson tweeted I expected a
richer darker birds of prey but enjoyed
what we got a lot of fun but it's touch
all over the place
tonally vengeance rarely brings the
catharsis we hope for yeah
good news friends we now know when we'll
get to see a second season of the
mandalorian and more of a biota so let's
take a look at what we can expect from
season 2 of the hit Disney Plus show
right now on the ketchup I have spoken
dizzy revealed in an earnings call this
week that the mandalorian season 2 is
coming in this October so special thank
you to John Favreau for starting to
write it before any of us even saw a
minute of season one your show money you
don't even know and so much happen at
the end of the certified fresh' first
season to give us an idea of what's to
come starting with what's gonna happen
to this really cute thing you know the
biggest thing to happen in pop culture
since Old Town Road well we know that
baby Oda is a foundling meaning that the
Mandalorian has a duty to search the
galaxy to find its rightful home or he
can train the child in accordance with
the way because you know this is the way
now Yoda species is actually one of the
few remaining mysteries in the vast Star
Wars lore so while their travels could
reveal little tidbits about where the
child and Yoda for that matter came from
it's one mystery that could very well
remain forever unsolved in the Star Wars
canon hopefully we also get to find out
what his real name is so we can stop
calling it baby Oda but for now we'll
just go with Tyco ITT's guests Nigel hey
Nigel but one thing we do know is that
their travels will no doubt hit a few
space bombs thanks to people like
Giancarlo Esposito azmuth gideon and
remember the last time we saw MOC he was
in possession of the dark saber giving
fans their first live-action look at the
weapon as far as the history of the dark
saber goes allow me to nerd splain it
was built a long long time ago by the
first Mandalorian to become a Jedi it
was later at the center of the Jedi
Mandalorian conflict and then ultimately
became a symbol of power to the
Mandalorian people so it could be menos
destiny to try and take possession and
use it to unite what's left of the
Mandalorian warriors as if mando
couldn't get any cooler but the dark
sabers popped up in both the rebels and
Clone Wars animated series and
considering that Favreau's main
collaborator Dave Filoni has been a
major player in those series the dark
saber could very well be the key
to a character like Bo Catan crossing
over from animation to live-action
equipment I'm here to rescue you that's
all you need to know another adventure
we could see with baby Odin mando whose
true name is ginger and could be the
continued defense of the planet Navarro
seen at the end of season 1 since we
know that both Carl Weathers and Gina
Carano will be returning
and thanks to a tweet from Jon Favreau
back in December we'll get to learn how
this returning gomorian last seen in
Return of the Jedi will fit back into
the story and while it seems unlikely
that the wandering of mando and his
family will be as directionless as it
was in the first season we still expect
to see some more of those self-contained
stories it's a strategy that lends
itself to utilizing different great
directors like Bryce Dallas Howard and
Taika Waititi in season 1 and with Jon
Favreau and Carl Weathers stepping
behind the camera in season 2 and if all
that is not enough to get you excited
Disney's Bob Iger hinted in the earnings
call that he's considering Mandalorian
related spin-off shows by infusing the
show with more characters and taking
those characters in their own direction
fingers crossed at Taika Waititi IG 11
is first up
this is not a joke
moonlight is won Best Picture moonlight
Best Picture get ready for fancy dresses
little gold men and really long speeches
because the Oscars are almost here and
who will be the night's biggest winners
we're talking predictions right now on
the ketchup the hostess Oscars are live
on ABC this Sunday and if there's one
thing we know it's that the person who
knows the least about movies will win
your office ballot pool but if there's a
second thing we know it's that Joaquin
Phoenix will win for Best Actor can you
introduce me as Joker the star of Joker
has already taken home ten Best Actor
Awards this season according to our
awards leaderboard including sag BAFTA
and Golden Globe wins and even though
Adam driver was equally fantastic in
marriage story and sang Stephen Sondheim
there's no reason to believe that
Joaquin won't add one more trophy to the
case on Sunday another likely shoo-in
based on what we've seen this award
season is Renee Zellweger
for Best Actress in the certified fresh'
Judy it's her first Oscar nomination
since 2004 when she won for Best
Supporting Actress in Cold Mountain
despite going up against huge names like
Theron Johansson and Ronan Zellweger's
deeply committed performance as Judy
Garland is strong enough to carry her
all the way to the Oscar stage but if I
can't do it again
now when it comes to we think the win
for Best Director let me tell you a
story once upon a time in Hollywood
there was a director named Quentin
Tarantino who did an amazing job
directing a great film but it just so
happened to be the same year that a
director named Sam Mendes directed a
single continuous shot war movie called
1917 and the work he did was just too
good to ignore which is why 20 years
after winning four American Beauty Sam
will take home his second directing
Oscar on Sunday lost time but who's
giving the last speech of the night is
really what matters
they will be holding an Oscar for Best
Picture and this year we think it will
be writer director bong joon-ho the man
behind the hit South Korean film
parasite yes bong hi you heard it right
here
best picture both critics and fans love
parasite which is certified fresh' at 99
percent with an audience score of 93
percent and USA TODAY's Brian true it
may have said it best when you wrote
parasite attaches to you and it doesn't
let go but it does it in like a totally
good way trust me by the way parasite is
also our pick for best foreign language
film and best editing but if you truly
want to win your Oscar ballot be sure to
watch our breakdown of every category
complete with insider secrets and
predictions on the Rotten Tomatoes
YouTube page and for the latest awards
coverage head on over to Rotten Tomatoes
calm all right friends thank you for
tuning in to the weekly catch-up on
YouTube make sure to tap that subscribe
button and notification mail so you
don't miss any future episodes at the
ketchup
as always I'm nas for us and we'll see
you guys next week
[Music]